en rappelant en préambule les scores
élevés du fn lors des dernières
régionales dans l'yonne et dans le
sénonais en particulier avec près de 41
% des voix
julien odoul a répété à plusieurs
reprises que son parti est le premier du
département avant de surfer sur les
sujets récurrents et cher au front
national
c'est pas le fond commerce et les
préoccupations là ce soir que ce soit
mashaal le pen ou moi même
on a parlé d' exclusion territoriale n'a
parlé de disparition du service public
de fermeture des gendarmeries
on a parlé d'immigration massive
puisqu'il ya toujours des migrants qui
arrivent dans nos communes et notamment
à saint brieuc vinolas qui fait
l'actualité
on veut être extrêmement présents tout
au long de cette année pour recueillir
un maximum de
gérer les attentes des habitants
viennent devant une petite salle comble
marion maréchal-le pen a elle aussi
martelé les idées de son parti en vue
des échéances de 2017
nous allons faire ces choses ensemble
les ânes être dur ça va être long ça va
être fastidieux certainement mais pour
se consoler je prends une phrase victor
hugo qui rien n'est plus fort qu'une
idée dont l'heure est venue et je sais
je suis sûr que vous savez aussi que
l'objectif de ce premier rendez-vous
patriote est ainsi clairement affichée
continué de progresser dans l'yonne
partie de cette france rurale et
périphériques d'une certaine manière qui
a beaucoup souffert continue d'ailleurs
de souffrir qui fait partie des grands
oubliés des politiques publiques et sur
lesquels voilà maintenant les français
ont cessé de sutter tout ce qu'elle a
dit c'est que la vérité c'est tout rien
l'odeur ça va crescendo et je pense
qu'on a besoin justement que ça aille
crescendo jusqu en 2017 ou faux
on convainc que l'on arrive à faire
passer aux plus grands noms aux idées
qui comme moi sont les bonnes et depuis
des dizaines d'années des militants qui
compte aussi sur cette relève pour voir
leurs ambitions enfin se concrétiser